>> Tucker: THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS FINALLY FINISHED ITS
PROBE OF THE DEPUTY CHAIRMAN OF
THE DNC KEITH ELLISON.
AS LAW FIRMS AS THE ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST ELLISON CAN'T BE
SUBSTANTIATED BECAUSE THE
ACCUSER DOESN'T HAVE VIDEOTAPE.
THEY ARE IGNORING HER WORD, THAT
WOULD BE CALLED VICTIM SHAMING.
KAREN HOUSLEY, THE U.S. SENATE
CANDIDATE FROM MINNESOTA AND SHE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
KAREN ARE YOU HAPPY WITH THIS
NEW STANDARD THAT THE DNC HAS A
TICKET RELATED?
>> NO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME.
IT JUST SO THE HYPOCRISY OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE DOUBLE
STANDARD THAT THEY DO HAVE.
I AM RUNNING FOR THE MEAT TO
AL FRANKEN SEAT AND MY OPPONENT
IS STILL OUT THERE CAMPAIGNING
WITH THEM.
SHE SAYS THAT KEITH ELLISON
CATEGORICALLY DENIES THESE
ALLEGATIONS.
THEREFORE SHE BELIEVES THEM AND
SHE STANDS WITH THEM.
ONE IT IS BRETT KAVANAUGH OR A
REPUBLICAN THEY WANT TO PULL A
INVESTIGATION.
IT SHOWS THE HYPOCRISY.
THE INVESTIGATION WAS DONE OF
KEITH ELLISON WHO WAS THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE DNC PARTY, DEAD BY
THE LAW FIRM OF A DEMOCRATIC OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY MINNESOTA.
IT IS LIKE THE FOX
WATCHING THE HENHOUSE.
KAREN MONAHAN, KEITH ELLISON'S
FORMER GIRLFRIEND.
SHE IS BEGGING FOR SOMEBODY TO
LISTEN TO HER BUT THE DEMOCRATI
DEMOCRATIC'S AND THE COMPLETE
HYPOCRISY THAT THEY ARE NOT
LISTENING.
>> Tucker: HAVE NO IDEA IF THE
ALLEGATIONS ARE CORRECT OR NOT.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW.
I WOULD WITHHOLD JUDGMENT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S WHAT
PEOPLE WOULD DO.
I AM SURPRISED BY THE REACTION,
HAS THE PRESS IN MINNESOTA, THE
PAPER AT MINNEAPOLIS BUT HOW DO
KEITH ELLISON TO EXPLAIN WHAT
EXACTLY THIS IS ABOUT?
>> NO ABSOLUTELY NOT.
IT IS DEAD SILENT AMONG THE
MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS AND
MINNESOTA.
ALL WE HEAR ABOUT IS BRETT
KAVANAUGH AND HOW WE SHOULD HAVE
A FULL FBI INVESTIGATION.
THE MEDIA IS QUITE IN MY
OPPONENT TINA SMITH IS OUT THERE
FULLY CAMPAIGNING AND SUPPORTING
KEITH ELLISON AND NOBODY, NOBODY
IS BRINGING THESE ACCUSATIONS OR
CALLING FOR AN INVESTIGATION.
I DID.
I CALLED AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL MINNESOTA TO DO
A FULL INVESTIGATION OF KEITH
ELLISON BECAUSE THE VOTERS OF
MINNESOTA, THEY WANT TO KNOW
BEFORE THEY VOTE TO THE POLLS.
WHO IS KEITH ELLISON?
HAS HE REALLY DONE THESE THINGS
TO HIS GIRLFRIEND?
>> Tucker: I CAN KEEP UP WITH
WHAT THE RULES ARE BECAUSE THEY
CHANGE SO OFTEN.
QUICKLY, AREN'T WE SUPPOSED TO
BELIEVE THE WOMAN?
I KEEP HEARING THAT.
>> SEXUAL-HARASSMENT ABUSE,
DOMESTIC ABUSE, DOES ALL WRONG.
EVERY ACCUSER SHOULD BE HEARD.
AGAINST KEITH ELLISON, THESE ARE
SOME SERIOUS ACCUSATIONS.
NOBODY IS LISTENING.